guys it's Comic Con week
you're either in San Diego walking the
floor go into some panels or stuck at
home looking at me on your computer
screen hi in honor of Comic Con we've
brought in some of our good friends of
the show to talk about comic book theme
movies you've seen them all over TVs an
actor in a very funny comedian Mike
Carlson hello and from the schmoes no
show Kristian harloff how's it going us
we're talking comic themed movies
Christian let's start with you yeah
let's talk worst I'm gonna go ahead and
i'ma say something kind of recent oh and
I'm gonna go with the Green Lantern
Green Lantern is so cool I've been so
much fun and it could been DC getting
back on the map it was it's a sloppy
mess whoever cut depth like the second
trailer knew what the tone of the movie
should be yeah brightest a blackest
night no evil shall escape my sight
here you go editor polish this turd yeah
yeah whoever did that does deserve an
award I like oh you know your best turd
polishing yes John Smith your second
choice second one is not too hard to
pick because Michelle Pfeiffer great
Cowell Anne Hathaway pretty decent Helen
Halle Berry ha ha ha oh my god I've
watched it once and every day am i mad
at you now because not talking about it
I thought I was gonna forget you're back
you're back in that zone but you gotta
admit she had some moves on the court of
that awesome basketball seat
public service never watched that movie
and your number one most hated yeah I
don't know if I can say most hated it's
the worst and that's Batman or Robin we
mention different times here because
Batman and Robin is it's it's comedy
alright everyone chill however had this
movie not been a colossal failure as it
was we wouldn't have gotten the reboot
and right close to you know that what we
got with Nolan's version we would
probably gotten 596 all the big
conspiracy who knows it's it's terrible
it really is terrible but it's good it
is I would watch it right now though
cool Mike talk to us about some of the
worst comic book movies I'm gonna start
with two quick in one category to
obscure things there was a Generation X
TV movie and a Nick Fury TV movie both
the span of a couple years on Fox
I'll get that vampire's blood of atlas
sucking from her neck imagine David
Hasselhoff playing Nick Fury it's one
reason the cheeseburger he's eating a
cheeseburger on the Helicarrier yeah for
a kid who loved comics 15 minutes and I
just was ill like I felt sick to my
stomach now it's just straight
disappointment I've watched him again
there's nothing redeeming about them
number two I want to say Ninja Turtles
three didn't they have much less of a
budget for that one yes and the costumes
are really bad they go to Japan well
Leonardo gives mouth-to-mouth to a young
boy there's a shot at the end when they
knock the main villain off of the like a
big tall bridge or something and he's
falling and I swear to you he disappears
when he's falling and there's a good two
seconds and then there's a splash
they just gave up like they were just
like God finish it I don't care Mike
your your number one worst comic book
inspired movie yeah my number one I
think is gonna have to be Superman 3 it
opens with the weirdest attempt at
slapstick comedy you've ever seen and
it's just confusing it just and you're
watching going what were they thinking
my worst comic book movies GI Joe the
first yeah or the first one watch the
80s cartoon so much better
anything Punisher related dirty laundry
the the short yes Thomas Jane made yeah
that had potential
I'd give Jane another chance after that
housekeep Travolta wake from it yeah
worst I got to go with ghost rider too
it was such a mess of a movie there was
no sense to it and it really ruined my
day when I saw it fun fact about the
first Ghost Rider and another terrible
comic-book movie daredevil directed by
the same guy mark steven johnson who
should be banned from directing and even
going into a comic book shop could have
his own list okay so let's talk about
odd and underrated what's an underrated
comic book movie I was gonna go Scott
Pilgrim who really like but yeah I was
gonna go somewhere else with that I want
a graphic novel and I'm gonna go V for
Vendetta I don't know it's just one of
my favorite ones like Superman Returns
especially after seeing the new Superman
where I left the theater depressed at
least you get a nice warm feeling from
it I'm not on that side at all because
of that movie was like drinking a bottle
of nyquil for me it was so boring and I
fell asleep I'm okay with pushing
Superman Returns away put the movie on
you'll go right to bed you'll feel
really nice when you wake up that's how
you should mark it yeah that's it yeah
if you want it if you want to see a
movie that'll put you right to sleep see
Bryan Singer's new movie tight pants my
most underrated it's close Dredd is
pretty awesome but people like that
movie one that gets hated on way too
much Watchmen so true to the graphic
novel I love that and that opening
sequence one of the best pieces of
filmmaking in the past decade yeah it's
like I don't hate it yeah but like I've
read Watchmen a bunch of times and it's
really good and why not just see it
lived out on-screen visual yet it's a
credible and authorities yes and okay
yeah but it's good I don't hate it it's
good like it's not my favorite but I
feel it's definitely under ink so did
you agree with us disagree what's your
most hated comic book movie leave a
comment in the section below best
comment gets a $25 gift card from Best
Buy
courtesy of cinnamon al from Best Buy
also we'll be down at Comic Con shooting
a screen junkies show and I'll be doing
a show called the tournament of nerds
check out the description below both of
you guys are gonna be at Comic Con right
yep right Mike Carlson Kristian harloff
thanks for being here fellas and thank
you for watching screen junkies
I'm holodeck bye-bye